Dear friends, those three strengths add up to one word: opportunity.
Tokyo 2020 offers a gateway to the vast, young continent of Asia.
Home to more than four billion people, including more than one billion young people.
In fact, more young people live inside of this circle than outside.
Tokyo will offer seven years for your sport to grow in this important market.
The games will deliver the biggest live primetime TV audience in history,...
...the biggest local ticketing market, and the greatest possible commercial success.
Already, our bid has 21 corporate sponsors,...
...and the JOC is experiencing record sponsorship levels.
Corporate Japan will support the games,...
...and ensure the IOC can focus on your own crucial programs to promote Olympism worldwide.
Our pioneering plan also offers a model of how to host the games in the center of a major city.
The starting point was our strong proposal from the 2016 bid,...
...which we improved, thanks to input from the IOC, athletes, IFs and NOCs.
I will give three examples.
First, the village, which is now in a much better place and bigger...
...and with a bed for every athlete.
Second, the new Olympic stadium, which will be a major new landmark,...
...and where every athlete can have a seat to enjoy the Opening Ceremony.
And third, an even more compact venue plan.
I will conclude in French.
I have already said this several times in the past but I've never said it in French.
We have kept the best and improved the rest.
Lastly, let me say what emotion and gratitude I feel...
...for the friendships we've been able to forge over the last 20 years.
Today, on behalf of these friendships, I call upon your trust.
And also in the name of these friendships.